qui dit nouvelle semaine dix nouveaux
blocs notes au programme ilc et qui juge
les stars la revanche d'un sdf et le
vent autour de michel drucker et on
commence avec le désormais célèbre
classement du journal de mickey
chaque année des livres un sondage avec
les stars les plus aimés 17 14 ans un
sondage importants dont soprano a une
nouvelle fois occupé la première place
arrive ensuite le duo de rappeurs
toulousain big flo et oli et le magicien
eric antoine la place de leader que
soprano connaît bien puisqu'il occupe
quasiment chaque année depuis 2017
merci on passe maintenant à une histoire
improbable paris match qui a une
nouvelle fois été attaquée pour avoir
publié des photos d'une personne sans
son autorisation sauf que choses pas
commune ce n'est pas une célébrité qui a
attaqué le magazine mais un sans
domicile fixe en 2018 la photo de cet
homme de 48 ans a été utilisé par le
magazine pour illustrer un article sur
les preneurs de crack dans le métro une
utilisation illégale sur laquelle il a
décidé de l'attaquer
résultat il vient d'empocher 40000 euros
une belle revanche on termine avec une
bonne nouvelle le retour sur les écrans
de michel drucker
après sa longue rémission si tu as une
opération délicate l'animateur star de
france bleu a décidé d'annoncer son
retour via une bande-annonce originale
athénée c'est comme le vélo ça sous
leopard rendez vous donc dimanche sur
son canapé rouge
quant à notre prochain bloc note qu'il
faudra attendre vendredi prochain d'ici
là soyez sages et portez vous bien
[Musique]
j'ai dit on est partis pour un bon
record de michel drucker je serai devant
j'ai eu au téléphone il m'a dit je suis
reparti pour 15 ans c'est clair minima
il est une patate d'enfer et en plus
vous y serez non dimanche juste après
l'émission
c'est beau un ami chez lequel vous a
fait débuter pour ceux qui ne le serait
pas oui merci de préciser sa bonne
information que personne n'avait
même si je fais ce métier